mon travail avec son nouveau plan la
Ville de Montréal à l'intention de mieux
desservir les quartiers laissés pour
compte comme moreal Nord
à Montréal trois nouveaux tronçons du
rêve du Réseau Express vélo devrait être
implanté sur Jean-Talon en Ré bourrassa
et Lacordaire tout situé dans le nord de
l'île de Montréal moins garni en piste
cyclables ces 200 km de voies cyclable
qui s'ajouteront ou 800 km existants un
investissement d'une valeur de 30
millions de dollars par an avec sa
vision vélo Montréal veut offrir plus de
prévisibilité aux usagers de la route on
le voit en ce moment là le stress que la
fermeture de la moitié du tunnel
occasionnée et la Ville s'engage à bien
consulter la population et ce avant
chaque première pileté de terre c'est
vraiment de travailler avec la société
civile donc faire preuve de flexibilité
pour s'assurer quand on déploie un
chantier on n'est pas en train de de
générer plus de problèmes que d'autres
vélo Québec salut l'initiative ce qui
est très important c'est de relier les
quartiers qui ont pas nécessairement de
lien cyclables on va parler de Parc
Extension Saint-Michel Montréal Nord et
certains de ces liens cyclables seront
érigés en face de commerce ce qui peut
amener son lot de friction les gens ont
l'habitude s'arrêter sur le bord ici
donc j'imagine si un pistic là ça va
réduire le l'espace de stationnement ou
plus de clients selon certains ça va
faire plus de gens des gens qui vont
passer selon toi par exemple qui nous
est ce qui va avoir une bicyclade puis
on a toujours pas vu dans tous les cas
la collaboration de tous semblent
nécessaire pour arriver à la meilleure
cohabitation possible vous avez des
besoins les automobilistes nous avons
des besoins une bicyclistes les jeunes
ont des besoins c'est vraiment de
pouvoir rassembler cet écosystème-là ici
Gabriel prout Radio-Canada Montréal